LORRAINE CINK: Landing a
synergy attack can even
stun stronger enemies
and bosses when
performed at the right time.
Yas, stunning.
Hi, I'm your
complimentary upgrade.
I'm Lorraine.
And I'm your first
class hot towel.
I'm Langston.
This is Earth's
Mightiest Show.
Where we talk about all
of the most vacationist
stuff in the Marvel universe.
Totally a word!
It's summertime, so
we are getting ready
for the ultimate nerd vacation.
That's right, y'all.
It is time for San
Diego Comic Con 2019!
We will be there on the
ground with Marvel Live.
Yeah.
We're going to be bringing
you everything from Marvel's
biggest stars to comic book
creators to the world's
best cosplay, all weekend long.
Yes.
Hey, make sure you join us
when we kick off Thursday
at 11:00 AM Pacific time.
And livestream every
dang day through Sunday.
It is a marathon,
not a sprint.
What is your favorite
thing about Comic Con?
Oh, Lorraine, what
a tough question.
I love the stage events.
I got to say, I love
the cosplay competition,
seeing all the ideas you come up
with for different characters.
I remember we had Spider-Man
in the Spider buster armor.
And then he was wearing
a Spider-Man mask
underneath the
Spider-Man helmet.
The reveal was great.
We all cheered.
LORRAINE CINK: That
is just commitment.
LANGSTON BELTON: It's perfect.
Oh, my goodness.
What about you, Lorraine?
I have to say, my
favorite things are actually
people, which are the fans!
We get to talk to the
fans all the time.
But it's so nice to get
to have people talk to us.
And you just will be walking
the hallway and be like,
I like your shirt.
Are we best friends?
We're best friends.
I have lifelong
friends from Comic Con.
You will, too.
You'll go in a booth, too.
You'll have a magical adventure.
It's going to be great.
And hey, make sure
you tune in on July 18
through the 21 on
Marvel.com and across all
of Marvel social media.
I'm so excited.
I'm not going to sleep until
the very day of Comic Con.
No, we'll need you to.
No, I can't.
You'll lose your mind.
But that's not the only big
thing happening next week,
right?
The MARVEL ULTIMATE
ALLIANCE 3: The Black Order
is coming to the Nintendo
Switch on July 19.
That's next week, y'all.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
Which is why I've
got the download
on what you need to know
before you play the game.
To the gaming lounge!
Yeah!
The wind.
Here are five things that
you need to know about MARVEL
ULTIMATE ALLIANCE 3: The
Black Order before you
get the game on July 19.
First up, unlock your potential.
Each character has
up to four abilities,
which unlock as each character
reaches a certain level.
Hot tip-- use experience
cubes as a quick way
to unlock your favorite
character's full potential.
Next up, team up with timing.
Characters can amplify
their abilities
by synergizing with
another teammate
who has a compatible ability.
Hot tip-- landing a synergy
attack cannot only lead
to greater damage,
but can even stun
stronger enemies and bosses when
performed at the right time.
Yas.
Stunning.
Get it?
Team up your teams!
You don't need to pick four
characters of the same team
to gain a team bonus.
Just having two or
three from the same team
can boost your team.
Hot tip-- be sure to experiment
with various team combinations
to find the right set of
bonuses that work best for you.
Teamwork makes the dream work.
Don't be afraid to be
passive aggressive.
Let me explain that.
Each character has either
passive or active abilities
that make them unique
from each other.
Experiment with each character,
as their unique ability
might be what you need to clear
that hard to beat challenge.
Hot tip-- Hulk has
attack armor, which
allows him to blow
through enemy attacks,
while Wolverine's healing
factor allows him to recover
vitality when idling.
Go extreme in your boss battles.
Alliance Extreme attacks
are your character's
strongest ability.
Using them at the right
time against a boss
is the quickest way to stagger
them or to do big damage.
Hot tip-- choose wisely between
the two Alliance Extreme
attacks during boss
battles to increase
your chances of victory.
And there you have it.
Go preorder MARVEL ULTIMATE
ALLIANCE 3: The Black Order
now, so that you can
play it on Nintendo
Switch starting on July 19.
And I'm back!
Ooh.
Whew.
He freezes sometimes.
I know what I'm going to
do with my summer, though.
I'm going to be playing
MARVEL ULTIMATE ALlIANCE
3: The Black Order, baby.
- Oh, yeah.
I'll be with you.
Yeah, please be sure to
preorder the game now.
Or get it in stores on July 19.
Oh, it looks so fun.
I am going to smash the crap
out of Proxima Midnight.
You know what you did.
You're dead to me.
[HISSING]
- Oh!
Oh, OK.
Well, listen, hey, life
can't all be fun and games
unless you're Ryan Penagos,
AKA Agent M, who does nothing
but have fun and play games.
I know.
In fact, he even got to
swing by Marvel Studios
and learn about how
Spider-Man, Far From Home
whips off the screen.
Oh, check it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, Marvel fans.
Ryan Penagos, AKA Agent M here.
Going to give you a little bit
of a behind the scenes chat
and a look at Spider-Man,
Far From Home,
but I'm not doing that alone.
I've got 3D Stereoscopic
Supervisor, Evan Jacobs here.
So you're the guy who helps
us get Spider-Man to thwip off
the screen.
- That's exactly right.
- I like that.
That's pretty cool.
A lot of people--
a lot of our fans, let's say,
go see the movie more than once.
And so this is
like a way to go--
you saw it in 2D
that first night.
But you go back the second night
or the third night or whatever.
And you see it in 3D.
And you go, oh, my god.
It's like seeing a new movie.
One of the things
that I want to dig into
is, like, just the
biology of it all.
How does that affect the work
that you and your team do?
Well, if you think about it,
we experience the world in 3D
all the time, right?
With our two eyes
taking the world in,
and our brain is taking
those two separate images
and fusing them
and giving you an--
what we call depth perception.
When you go to the movies, for
many years, it's been flat.
Which, in a weird
way, is what people
have come to think is normal.
3D in the cinema, though, is
a little bit different than 3D
in real life, in
that it's actually
a magic trick of sorts.
But we're going to trick your
brain into thinking that things
have dimension and depth.
But at the end of the day,
you put those glasses on.
And hopefully, it
feels like Spider-Man
is right there with you.
You know, in the trailer
for Spider-Man, Far From Home,
we saw this water creature.
We saw a big fire monster
sort of destroying the bridge.
And, like, all these things
that Spider-Man is up against.
Of all the fun elements
in play in Spider-Man,
Far From Home, I would imagine
the most is Spider-Man himself.
Because he's Spider-Man.
He's the greatest
superhero of all time.
EVAN JACOBS: Well, what's cool
about him is he does a lot more
flying around in this movie.
So there's a lot of
fun opportunities.
Anytime we can get
him airborne and off--
you know, or shooting webs or
whatever, there's a lot of--
those are always great, because
it can bring the audience
on the ride with you.
I want to talk a little
bit about rotoscoping.
Yeah.
It's so much fun.
What is rotoscoping, in terms
of the stereoscopic experience
that you're working on?
The basic idea is tracing
photograph images, right?
If you think about what 3D
is in the context of a movie,
you sort of start with
this flat image that would
be sitting right on the screen.
And then you want
some of the things
to be identified as
distant background,
some in the mid-ground,
some in the foreground.
And to do that with a flat, 2D
image that you photographed,
you got to retrace
the whole thing.
So you trace every
single thing in the frame
that you want to have
on a different layer.
That's how you separate
these people, right?
That's the first
step of this process.
And that's what we
call rotoscoping.
There's a procedural process
that would maybe take the edges
and stretch them out, but
that doesn't look very good.
So pretty quickly,
you've got to go in
and hand paint all that stuff.
So you're rotoscoping
the entire film?
Every single frame.
Every-- I'm trying
to process, like,
the amount of people that you
need, the manpower, the time.
And the attention to
detail, because it's not a--
you know, the way
you describe it,
it doesn't seem like
something-- just
someone puts their headphones
on and blindly does it.
No, it just--
it's a crazy process.
But you know, one of the things
that's really fun about it
is when you get a filmmaker
in at the end of the thing,
and you've done a sequence,
and you've taken their film
and presenting it back to
them in a completely new way.
And then they react, you
know, as if-- as if they've
never seen the movie.
That's so cool, though.
That's just the
craziest thing.
Yeah, it's really fun.
One of the things that I think
is, you know-- differentiates
the Marvel films from some
of the other films that
are out there in the marketplace
that are released in 3D
is that we're really
involved all the way through.
I heard a term
as we were starting
to put this together, something
called a depth script.
Yeah.
What is the depth script?
And how does that play
into this whole process?
If you think about it, 3D can
be just like a musical score
or just about any other part of
a film, in that you essentially
have a depth script.
And you sort of can be,
like, I can make it very
deep in this section,
because it's going to be
a very exciting 3D moment.
And then I can give
the audience a break,
and, you know, come
down a little bit.
And then I go back up
again for something else.
And that kind of ebb
and flow of the process
is a creative
control that we have,
so that people experience it.
So if you think about it, just
in the musical context, if you
just kept it loud all
the time, you wouldn't
really know that it was loud.
You know?
You're not always doing
the cool 3D just to do it.
RYAN PENAGOS: Yeah.
You're doing it if it affects
the-- if it helps the movie.
Yeah.
Evan, I'm super excited
to see this movie.
You have completely sold me
here, this whole conversation.
But for our fans who, you
know, have seen it once,
maybe haven't seen
it in 3D yet, why
do they have to see it in 3D?
It's a completely
different experience in 2D.
So the elementals
are incredible.
There's some other stuff I
can't talk about that's amazing.
What?
And really, really
fun and disorienting
and cool and exciting.
And it's going to get--
we're going to take
them on a ride.
So it's definitely--
I'm very proud of this movie.
And I'm proud of the
work that we did.
There's some of the films
that we work on really
lend themselves to the format.
And this is one of those films.
Avoiding spoilers, I can't
tell you much about it,
but you gotta go see it.
I'm telling you.
The cameras are off.
You can tell me everything.
All right.
OK.
There you have it, everybody.
Evan, thank you so much.
I am a full convert
into the 3D experience.
I need it.
I want it.
I hope you guys want it, too.
Spider-Man, Far From
Home is in theaters now.
Be sure to see it in 3D.
Oh, so good.
I love Spider-Man in 3D,
especially because Spider-Man--
by virtue of being
Spider-Man-- is always
swinging through the buildings.
And that's so cool in 3D.
Yeah.
And I got to say, all the visual
effects in every single frame,
just going through
every single frame
and doing all these minor
adjustments and minor tweaks,
hey, thank you to
that VFX team--
Oh, my god.
--for making
Spider-Man look so good.
Someone get these
people coffee.
Oh, my goodness.
That's a lot of work.
You know, I'm going to--
I think I'm going to take
a European vacation myself
like Spidey.
I'm just not going
to fight anyone.
Don't try to make me.
It's my vacation.
I'm looking for the fights.
- Oh!
- I want to fight some baddies.
- All right.
- Yeah.
Well, listen.
Hey, tell us where in
the Marvel universe
you think would make
the best vacation spot.
And use the hashtag
#EarthsMightiestShow.
Oh, and this is cool.
This weekend,
Marvel has revealed
some of the Marvel merch
available exclusively
at San Diego Comic Con.
Go head over there and watch
that video now on Marvel.com.
- I'm Langston.
- I'm Lorraine.
And this is Marvel.
Your universe.
[MUSIC PLAYING]